without naming names can you give us
some of the distribution offers you've
had for Lola so Lola one
um the process was when I did a Premiere
before cover happened the day of covert
um I had a whole plan I was going to put
in AMC do movie theaters all that didn't
work out
so I was like oh come my whole marketing
tragedy my last movie was movie theaters
that guy collapsed so I did his big
festival called American black Film
Festival one of the biggest festivals
out there
I've been made it online because covert
happened and I got a lot of GPU
companies to contact me
and one contact me called Homestead
entertainment
and they kept telling me Antoine
you know Netflix and you know the BTS a
bit of gonna say no and that was right
because I have big names but they said
go to 2B TV
so I was like what's 2B TV but we're so
programmed that if it's not a Netflix or
Hulu or BT we're not looking into that
so I said so I gave in so I did I did a
deal with homestead
at first I was kicking and streaming but
the CEO Rob Johnson said Anton trust me
you want to make something with 2B TV
say whatever
my first check was nice
so 2btv is amazing platform for
independent filmmakers when the big
networks say no
um it's a great split they gave you 50
of the ad revenue and long as you
promote and really out there getting all
your friends and family it's free too
you don't have to pay for nothing
because the reality is the film business
is right now the music business no one
pays for music anymore they treat them
everything now they're saying they would
film business people ain't trying to pay
for your films this is a big film so you
want to stream it for free so two is a
great platform when you can't get to the
big Networks
no subscription model for 2B okay nope
at all and it's great you send the app
is on your phone like and I didn't
notice a lot of people got 2B that's
nothing I wasn't educated I thought that
to me whatever but to be have a big
market and it's a great platform yep are
you able to get like the age
demographics and where people live no no
okay that's something I want to work on
my next project
when you talk about the revenue that's
generated from having Lola on 2B can you
talk about what you mean by good
so
my first three weeks on 2B because you
get paid when you sign a Distribution
Company you get paid by quarterly first
quarter second call to third quarter
it's like every three to four months so
I came at the end of the quarter so I
got to get paid that last quarter
because I came at the end like three
weeks and the first week was like around
around five thousand dollars
um it's a way better back end than
Amazon Amazon Prime give you pennies so
if you're a filmmaker and you want to
make some money off your Independent
films try to get on tubing and get a
great Distribution Company that could
help you get on 2B and um and you will
see the results but you gotta you gotta
promote it
when you say promote it you mean what do
you do Facebook ads yeah Facebook ads
Instagram ads don't just put it online
and do one or two posts you gotta be
consistent if that's not you hire
someone that will be consistent online
doing different marketing strategies for
it when I release level one this is a
woman empowerment film I release it
during women's month
business side
I did a podcast for it
a limited podcast for it leading up to
the release talking about
women empowerment things I interviewed a
lot of powerful women in my life and I
did an interview I saw a marketing
promotion leading up roll out and um it
did really well did really well
before you had Lola won on 2B we talk
about some of the offers that came in
from other Distributors for the film
um it was a lot of distribution
companies and I did not go with them
because a lot of them are predators a
lot of the becomes our predators
they tell you I put your movie
everywhere but the reality is they don't
even have that reach so if you're a
filmmaker unless you got a big name in
your film or you have a great marketing
strategy
it doesn't make no sense to put your
film everywhere because at the end of
the day
your order is only gonna go to one or
two platforms so let's break it down
Amazon Prime is really for exposure
you're not gonna make a lot of money on
Amazon unless you're a big film
um Apple TV
unless you're getting a license fee no
one's really buying it no Independence
over ten twenty dollars you might get
some money but it's just it's crumbs so
for me
I'm a realist
I'm not gonna say here's my film
everywhere and everybody gonna watch my
film that's not gonna happen try to
stick to one and two platforms so you're
gonna do Amazon do Amazon do 2b don't do
a whole bunch of platforms it's just
it's just a waste and another reason why
I don't like that you want to control
your money if you have a Distribution
Company they stick up with you from
everywhere
you got to count that money you gotta
know where that money coming from and
sometimes a lot of distribute companies
they're not trustworthy you got to be
Catholic a lot of Distributing companies
don't have your best interests they
Predators independent films so you want
to be very loud research the number one
reason that you want to do and this is
why I went with homestead entertainment
the best research is if a Distribution
Company got filmmakers contact the film
exactly already making money
and you're going to find out majority
are not making no money staying in red
they're not making nothing make it like
a little Advanced and that's it when I
went to Homestead entertainment I
contacted four filmmakers all making
money and some of them show me their
receipts they do a statement so that's
the number one reason why like it's very
rare for if somebody could say have any
money while this bridge company
independently favored so you want to
really you know control your thumb be a
be realistic if you don't have no big
names in your film why you don't worry
about distribution like you got to be a
realist like I know my film I know I
have big names let's keep it simple
one to two platforms I know my money
gonna be at
it's not no it's my film is not no
network that's a Millions away and I
can't find the money so you just want to
be a realist when you do the deals and
get a lawyer
the final lawyer go online because those
contracts are crazy
so really find a lawyer read a contract
because I think that's your baby you
want to give a real baby to No Stranger
why don't be desperate like really read
those contracts and they have lawyers
website they will do it for free and if
you don't understand the language the
terms and the contract Google the words
this is everything I would do because
sometimes we don't have the money for
lawyers so you want to break it down and
then also too
you want to try your best in the
contracts
that you could order the Distribution
Company if you feel like you're not
getting your money so it has little
things like you know contracts but get a
lawyer and a lawyer will represent you
and say the right thing for you where do
you find a lawyer to do this for free
so they have some websites out there
that they would read a contract for you
I came into websites but even if not
um put that in your budget
just to read a contract because you
could get a you know as long as I didn't
cost a lot of money but it's some
lawyers that local lawyer that can read
a contract for you and break it down for
you not for a lot of money but put that
in your budget that you know you need a
lawyer to read the contracts what what
kind of hourly fee are you paying so you
have some lawyers play a fat fee I would
say do a flat fee don't do no I believe
tunnel listen this is what I want
workout flat fee there's tons of lawyers
that will work out flat fee for you what
do you think is reasonable
it's on your budget put on a person
reasonable for me might be reasonable
somebody else so it depends on your
budget
so you go with your budget but you
wouldn't get a lawyer
what do you think is unreasonable
because on the budget
like for me my lawyer was looking at my
contract was 1500. for me that's fine
but for someone else that's a lot of
money so you got to go with your budget
but
do you want to make that investment even
if you have to do a crowd for me because
that contract once you sign that
contract you can't go backwards so you
want to be very careful um with your
signing okay so you you only allotted
certain things that you wanted this
lawyer to do and you paid them yeah yeah
yeah you don't have to do a whole hourly
fee and everything you could don't
listen this is document read it tell me
what I need to know you know you work
out flat fee everything's negotiable no
people think you give you negotiate when
you reached out to these filmmakers that
were working with this Distribution
Company without naming their film or
their names first off how did you
contact them IMDb
so when you go on IMDb The District
numbers there so I want to contact them
so I was a phantom on Instagram called
them and also I so I told the district
company could I get so many numbers the
ones I didn't know they it was happy
giving any numbers and the numbers was
really good and I was happy so yeah
that's rare for any filmmaker two did it
say yes because usually you hate I ain't
making no money they gave me advance and
then another thing you don't want to do
so distribution companies be saying that
we have like a 50 000 budget for
marketing what marketing social media
they don't know how to do marketing so
when you sign your contract you said
you're not getting no marketing not
enough to don't take money or friend
you here's your percentage whoever is is
15 or 20 whatever the percentage is and
that's it because multitude companies
don't know a clue about marketing so
when they add that in their contract or
is it 50 000 marketing budget how it's a
lot of a line
okay and so you say
I don't want marketing to be part of my
package I do everything I'll do
everything right yeah just take this hit
again take the fee that you want to set
whatever's up and that's it because they
don't Market there's no just like so
they don't if you go on high-filled
distribution companies marketing they're
like maybe five likes 50 people fall in
them like what are you marketing to so
you gotta they take a prayer for a lot
of filmmakers a lot of bad distributes
comes out here but I must say Homestead
I had no homes entertainment no
complaints
and when you talk to these filmmakers
what kind of numbers were they providing
for you six figures
and what span of time six months
what type of films were these
documentaries Urban
African-American films gangster films
you know captain of the day is not the
film
it's your audience
you know you got to know your audience
like you know if you if you're doing a
Christmas film I love film a horror film
you have to build your audience for it
but they was doing and also it's free
like to be
great in my two is free so you guys just
watch commercials on it no you have to
because because at the end of the day
if you get a thousand people to watch
the film half of the majority are gonna
pay you know five ten hours of Ranger
film it's just not just I mean just read
that they're not but if I say my films
on this platform it's free it's easier
I'm not paying for nothing and then
signing up to two bit real easy you have
to put so much information in there